[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 1: Good
afternoon, everyone.
We're going to talk more
about new capabilities we're
releasing, as well as
the improvements we're
making to the platforms and
tools you use every day.
SPEAKER 2: Today, we are
excited to announce the new app
model for Android.
Using the Android App Bundle,
a new publishing format,
you can dramatically
reduce app size.
We're announcing Android
Jetpack, the next generation
of Android APIs to accelerate
Android development.
Jetpack is a set of
libraries and tools.
Jetpack's APIs are
integrated with the IDE, too.
For instance, Android Studio now
includes a navigation editor,
which works with the library.
You told us work on
Emulator boot time.
SPEAKER 3: Ready, set, go.
AUDIENCE: Ooh.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 3: I was not cheating.
It was not running
in the background.
SPEAKER 2: Slices are a cool,
new way to drive reengagement.
We wanted these to
be easy to build,
so you'll find templates
that are rich and flexible.
And because it's Jetpack,
Slices work on 95% of devices.
SPEAKER 4: And
starting today, you
can deeply customize the
appearance of your action.
First, we're making
it even easier
for you to promote your
action with something
new we call Action Links.
Right there at the bottom.
These are hyperlinks
that you can
use from anywhere that point
directly into your action.
Once users opt in,
Action Notifications
gives you a way to connect
with them about new features
and content.
These notifications
work on the phone,
even if users don't have
your Android app installed.
And you'll be able to
reengage with your users
on speakers, smart displays,
and other Assistant-enabled
devices.
After somebody engages
with your action,
you can prompt them to add
your action to their routine
with just a couple of taps.
SPEAKER 5: And we're incredibly
excited that Service Worker,
the underlying new API
that makes PWAs possible,
is now supported on
all major browsers,
including recently Edge
on Windows and Safari
on both desktop and mobile.
This is probably the most
important leap forward
for the web in the last decade.
Today, we're launching
Lighthouse 3.0, which
makes Lighthouse's performance
metrics even more precise,
and its guidance
even more actionable.
I'm happy to share that AMP
is evolving in some big ways.
Now, all AMP content
benefits from
a fast, free,
privacy-preserving cache
that optimizes page
loads, but they've
had these Google.com URLs.
So we're fixing that with a new
standard called web packaging.
We're expanding Chrome
OS to support developers
with the ability to securely
run Linux apps on Chrome OS.
[CHEERS]
[APPLAUSE]
So this means that many of
your favorite tools, editors,
and IDEs now work
on Chromebooks.
SPEAKER 6: We're
proud to announce
Material Theming, a major update
to the material design system.
Today, we're also
releasing two new tools
to make it faster to go from
design to implementation.
Material Theme
Editor-- this plug-in,
for the popular
application Sketch,
helps designers
create and customize
a unique material theme.
This is the tool used by
product teams at Google
to review and comment
on design iterations.
To make a material yours,
get started at material.io.
SPEAKER 7: Cloud TPUs are
now available to everyone,
and getting started is as
simple as following this link.
We've released a ML Kit
in beta, an SDK that
brings Cuckoo's machine
learning capabilities
to mobile developers
through Firebase.
We believe success
in AI should be
determined by your imagination,
not your infrastructure.
SPEAKER 8: Predictions applies
ML to your analytics data
and predicts the future
behavior of your users,
so you can take proactive
actions to optimize your app.
For example, you can lower
the difficulty of your game
for users who are likely
to abandon it, or send
special offers to users
who are likely to spend.
We're bringing together
Google's machine
learning technologies
from across Google
and making that available
to every mobile developer
working on Android and iOS.
And since ML Kit is
available through Firebase,
it's easy for you to take
advantage of the broader
Firebase platform.
SPEAKER 9: We're rolling
out a major update
to ARCore to help you create
even richer, more immersive
and interactive experiences.
That's why we've created
Sceneform, a brand new 3D
framework that makes it
easy for Java developers
to create ARCore applications.
Today, we're introducing
Augmented Images,
a new capability in
ARCore that makes
it possible to attach AR
content and experiences
to the physical images
in the real world.
With Cloud Anchors, we
actually allow multiple devices
to generate a shared,
synchronized understanding
of the world, so that multiple
phones can see and interact
with the exact same digital
content, in the same place,
at the same time.
SPEAKER 10: Wow, that
was a lot, very quickly.
Now, we still have a lot of
Google I/O awesomeness coming
your way.
Hit that subscribe
button, so you can stay up
to date with all the sessions
and things happening here
at Google I/O. See you around.